[Music]
tomorrow it's a huge day for romantic
gestures Valentine's Day is the second
biggest greeting card occasion of the
year after the winter holiday season but
because fire production costs lower
profit margins and arise in social media
and texting revenue in the greeting card
industry has been declining for by about
4% a year Meg Oliver's at a card store
in New York with how new players are
getting creative Meg good morning good
morning Americans will spend nearly 20
billion dollars on Valentine's Day
Millennials are shelling out the most on
average they'll spend about two hundred
dollars on cards gifts and other
celebrations and with many Millennials
tired of impersonal text messages and
social media posts greeting card
companies see an opportunity we should
throw a party
but let's not invite anyone else not
exactly your grandmother's greeting card
I love that one little thing you do you
know existing no flowery designs and
sappy messages that have long been a
staple of car dials
Mike Sayer and Melanie bridges started
their company easy tiger in 2013 they
wanted to strike a more casual an ironic
tone with a new kind of card sell
greeting cards to people who weren't
looking to buy greeting cards which was
how does that quick Korean I guess take
on if we can inspire people to send a
card when they don't have to the
relationship gets stronger people value
it more and so that we had to change a
lot of things in order to do it and so
part of that was vending machines how
did you come up with the idea to sell
cards and vending machines you know I
think I was just about bringing the
products where the people were and never
been a hangs out of coffee shops at key
coffee in Kansas City Missouri they
touched their first bright green vending
machine into the corner this is the big
statement piece I love this it's like a
gumball machine for awesome people
bought off Craigslist Mike and Mel
refurbished and repurposed vintage snap
machines to sell their cards around town
I want them to feel real conversational
so I like to observe people observe the
ways that they say things and put a
little twist on it
gone are the holiday specific captions
Mel is in charge of the artistic vision
while Mike writes the messages actually
our best-selling card today is helped me
understand how are we so much better
than everyone else
and so people love to have that
experience of together we're awesome a
sentiment they believe appeals to a
younger generation I feel like it's part
of that kind of casual ironic kind of
sense of humor that a lot of Millennials
have do companies like easy Tiger have
they filled a void for Millennials oh
absolutely yeah I'm Peter Doherty leads
the industry's trade organization the
way that the cards speak to you have
changed the snarky movement is is
connected in many ways to Millennials
the bigger companies they have seen what
the Millennials are doing and what
smaller companies are doing in general
and they are they're learning from that
more than six and a half billion
greeting cards are still sold a year but
the industry's revenue is declining
before the internet came in the greeting
card industry was really booming and
growing is it safe to say that it's
cotton flattened out a little bit yeah I
think that's safe to say I mean our card
category overall said has been stable
Lindsey Roy is hallmarks chief marketing
officer she says in terms of card
spending Millennials are the
fastest-growing group because when they
buy cards they spend more money on them
we've seen that Millennials are really
growing into that magic life stage for
cards sending maybe you're setting up
households or having kids or doing the
kinds of things that really just expand
your relationships
Millennials are hitting a sweet spot
they are absolutely hitting a sweet spot
although you won't see it anywhere on
their cards easy Tiger is fully funded
by Hallmark launched out of a project to
target Millennials Millennials as a
group are seeking cards that speaks to
them in a more authentic way Emily
McDonald's first attempt at an authentic
greeting card read more like an awkward
text message
Valentine I know we're not like together
or anything but it felt weird to just
not say anything so I got you this card
it's not a big deal it doesn't really
mean anything
there isn't even a heart on it so
basically it's a card saying hi forget
it now her biggest customers women 25 to
34 can buy cards that feel and sound
more like them I think that Millennials
are revitalizing the industry and we
want a card to be kind of a stand-in for
what what the best version of ourself
would say and so I think that you know
the more that we can speak to
Millennials the more they'll buy them it
might also surprise you that Millennials
are not only buying cards at a record
pace even in this digital age eighty
percent of Millennials are keeping these
cards as keepsakes John for like that
meg thanks I'm expecting a card from my
millennial friends